New York a city where people pride
themselves on having fine restaurants
and courageous palates but once a year
the Big Apple hosts a unique dinner that
even New Yorkers might find shocking
it's the annual gala of the Explorers
Club at the Waldorf Astoria Hotel the
highlight of the evening is the cocktail
hour where their finger food might have
legs a face or a tongue the cuisine
could be too extreme when the Waldorf
kitchen staff is cooking up a little
grub they're more used to cooking leg of
lamb than tarantula but exotic chef Jean
Rica has some new recipes in mind let me
show you what we have today
now some surprises that's yummy Oh tell
you huh sobbing like a little pretzel a
little the chef's may welcome the
challenge of transforming creatures into
cuisine but that doesn't mean they're
excited about handling the goods
Madagascar cockroaches later they're not
gonna bite you
thank you very tasty what type of
roaches are ya cockroaches are just one
of many outlandish ingredients Jeanne
brings into the kitchen the eyeballs are
soft olive oil will poach some of these
will slice them up will stuff some I
have testicles coming John
all right so flora teeth though they are
short the frenzy of transforming roaches
rodents and reptiles into culinary art
begins
if you present it properly it looks
advertising it's no longer that creature
there he wants to step on and run away
from but how do you make something with
an exoskeleton look
not to mention taste exquisite first of
all you need to make sure that when they
hit your tongue they're dead
just make sure you have the oil at 155
degrees so once you put it in you're
gonna cook you don't want these bad boys
alive in your stomach even the
tarantulas have their own special recipe
so what we're gonna do is put these in
this brandy we have and once we soak
them in here for about 20 minutes or so
we'll take them out we're then going to
skewer them take a piece we're going to
put in a deep fryer and what you're
gonna wind up having is something like
this the displays have been crafted into
perfect edible masterpieces or sushi
with crickets mealworms puff pastry are
balls very nitro-burning It's Showtime
could have any welcome to order for
Surya Jeanne anxiously awaits the guests
reactions
these explorers are getting face to face
with their food and swallowing their
fear from Madagascar let me see
outstanding how's eyeball it's very good
you see the facial changes and they go
to put this in your mouth um very unique
description on their faces I know how I
would describe it the Wow might be a
good word maybe a little shocking
grimace I'd be good work
are they still moving the theme of the
evening maybe adventure but some are
more thrill-seeking than others I don't
like spiders dead I know I'm not going
to eat them matter than fry that's for
sure they're just like the zoo but
they're dead despite a few timid diners
genes delicacies are a big hit the
eyeballs are all gone testicles are all
gone insects I think we're the biggest
surprise Oh
people were running to the tables for
the tarantulas and the scorpions
it's good it's a whole idea to just to
bring smiles to people's faces and we've
done it tonight so I think it's been a
great success